today marks a milestone that I'm rather
proud of and I wanted to share with all
of you out there in YouTube land whether
you're just happening upon this or
whether you're a regular viewer and this
Milestone has to do not with YouTube
itself although it does indirectly but
rather with the sadders lectures podcast
we have
today released the
1,000th episode of the podcast which I
think is kind of a a cool threshold to
pass and I thought we should do a little
bit you know make make a few remarks
about it tell you a bit about the
podcast to celebrate and so you know
thanks for being here with me I'm going
to tell you a few things about the
podcast but you know uh I do want to say
it's it's you know five years in it's
kind of an awesome thing to do lots and
lots of people have enjoyed it benefited
from it said nice things about it so you
know thanks to everybody out there who
watches shares and has good things to
say about the podcast so if you don't
know what the saders lectures podcast is
well it's a podcast that is uh housed or
hosted on Soundcloud which is a very you
know
common um place to put podcasts right
perhaps uh one of 20 out there I would
say and I decided you know five years
ago that was the one that I was going to
go with and now that's where it is now
all you can find all 1,000 episodes on
Soundcloud you can also find it on
Spotify and apple music and you know
everything under the Sun including
probably some platforms that I don't
even know about because everybody sucks
from the same RSS feed but you can only
get the latest 500 episodes in all of
those other platforms because that's the
way they work so I found out about this
when I hit around the I don't know
520th episode Mark and people were like
where's the old episodes I can't find
them and I was like well you got to go
to SoundCloud because that's where they
are now
fortunately I also have a page that I've
linked to below
where I've taken all of those podcast
episodes organized them into playlists
on Soundcloud where by the way you can
also download them every single one of
them and uh I've created this this list
of links that organizes all of these
according to time period and what kind
of text it is whether it's about
business ethics or about uh 20th century
psychology or literature or
philosophy uh time period and type of
content so it's it's really easy to find
I mean you can just type in Google
saddler's lectures and you'll be
surprised how many different things come
up and that's that's where you can find
all of these episodes and why did I do
this in the first place well for years
prior to 2018 when I started the podcast
I had a lot of people uh leaving
comments on my YouTube videos and saying
things like can I get this video in
podcast format or hey you should start a
podcast you know it's not enough to have
a a YouTube channel we want to we want
to listen to you we want to be able to
download your lectures and stuff like
that and so I thought about it and I was
like well I don't know that I actually
have the time for doing like a full
proper podcast where people are you know
sipping coffee and chitchatting and
shooting the breeze and then getting
into a topic and you know kind of
thinking about it together and all that
but I do have all these core concept
videos that I've been producing for
years and years and years that I you
know give my students as resources and
many other people use in their own
academic classes and lifelong Learners
love using to understand these texts
everything from you know perenties and
heraclitis up to 21st century thinkers
and everything in between so why don't I
start taking
those and I'll you know improve the
sound quality see what I can do to make
it a much easier to listen to thing take
out the hiss or the sound of a echoey
classroom take out all the ums and A's
and you knows and filler words and long
pauses and you know I'll Just Produce
them as podcast episodes and see if
people like it and as it turns out
people like it they've been listening to
it for quite a long time I went in today
and looked at the stats for the podcast
and what I found was really quite
astonishing over the last five years
there have been
764 th000 plays of episodes of this
podcast on you know sound Cloud Spotify
uh Google's thing Apple music pod toppin
you know all these different uh
platforms that are out there so not
quite a million but three4 of the way to
a million different listens now of
course there's a lot of repeat customers
you could say so it doesn't mean that a
million people have listened to the
podcast but you know it's it's a pretty
good number I I would estimate I've
probably reached at least 100,000 people
out there interested in philosophy and
literature and religion and politics and
psychology and other topics as well so
anyway um you know I've been covering a
a wide range of different thinkers and
as I mentioned you can find them all
organized in that list if you just uh
you know click show more and go to the
video description you'll see that and a
bunch of other links as well so I
thought it'd be you know an appropriate
time to take a little moment and
celebrate hitting this Milestone
Crossing that threshold um uh my plans
are to continue producing them maybe
I'll produce another thousand more maybe
maybe even more if people you know like
them um they turn out to be a very
useful resource that I can give to my
own students in face Toof face in online
classes I give to client clients when
they want to listen to things and lots
of other people I know are using them as
well um someday I'll probably do a
proper podcast but that day is not right
now um you know I've got a lot of other
projects that I'm doing I do these in my
spare time now if you'd like to support
the work that I do with this podcast you
might consider becoming a patreon
supporter again link is below um I I'll
also tell you something too Pat
supporters one of the perks that they
get early releases of these podcast
episodes so they're already at least six
or seven episodes ahead of view right
now uh at any given time because I I
generally will release as a batch these
podcast episodes to them and they get
the first chance to listen and and
download to them and then I release them
to the general public um if there's
other ways to support as well buy me a c
coffee um you can go directly to reason
iio and and you know just make a
donation if you're interested in
sponsorship I don't actually have any
sponsors at this time you can reach out
to me about that if you want to support
the uh world of you know online
philosophy well I'm I'm one of those
creators that you can help out but if
you just want to listen to them and
download them that's cool as well that's
what the majority of people all over the
world are doing another thing that I
found out that was really cool uh about
the stats of the podcast there's a map
that it shows you and literally on every
continent except for Antarctica there
are people listening to this podcast um
or at least have been listening to it I
I didn't like aggregate it by year or
something like that but you know North
America Europe which are kind of you
know expected South America Africa
Africa Asia Australia or Oceana people
all over the world are checking out this
this podcast in part because it delivers
exactly what the title suggests their
lectures by me about important
philosophical texts and thinkers and
topics so I just wanted to take a little
bit of time and chat with you about this
this cool Milestone that I've passed
um you know if you like the podcast
share it with people say nice things
about it if you want to chip in and help
me out with it that's cool too um and
you know we're going to keep on with it
and hopefully you know not too far down
the line we'll get to
celebrate uh 1,500 and 2,000 and who
knows how more episodes down the line so
that's all that I have for you I just
wanted to share that uh
you know nice little Milestone that I've
uh seen in my own professional life as
an educator online with all of you who
have been listening and uh contributing
for years and years and years so thanks
for uh you know listening to the end of
this and if you haven't already checked
out the podcast go ahead and click that
link and see all the different um
playlists that are available to you and
maybe you're going to hear something
that you want to if you're somebody who
already does listen to the podcast well
thanks for the support and the shares
and the likes and all of that sort of
stuff and for the attention which is a
limited resource in our time and I know
that you know you could be listening to
all sorts of other stuff so if you're
listening to the podcast that's cool by
me and you know if you want to leave
comments below I'll uh check them out
and respond to all of them otherwise you
know that's it for
now